[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning and welcome i invite you to
stand if you are able
with deep gratitude to the quinnipiac
people for this land on which we stand
my beloved yale family i invite you to
join me in the spirit of prayer
almighty and brilliant creator
fount of all life
here we stand in the splendor of this
morning
many and diverse expressions of one
living mystery which is beyond
all telling
we are gathered from all parts of your
world to serve a sacred purpose
we are the children of yesterday's
yearnings
and the embodiment of tomorrow's promise
on this day the continuing creation of
our lives awaits us
with ever increasing horizons of meaning
and responsibility
it is our unknown next
loving god here in this place of such
privilege and learning
bless our hearts our minds and our hands
as we begin
may we be tireless seekers of your truth
and ever gentle carriers of your light
let curiosity fuel us
and compassion guide us
as this new creation unfolds
awaken us to your genius in the midst of
ancient conversations contemporary texts
fossils and formulas
instill in us a lifelong thirst to know
more and in turn to share more
finally may our loved ones take pleasure
in the changes they will see in us
and may they be patient with the twists
and turns that will no doubt be between
wish
and fulfillment in this unknown next
for all that is spoken aloud in this
poignant life moment
and for that which rests silently in our
hearts
as your loving people we say
amen
please be seated
thank you chaplain coogler
president salovey colleagues students
families and friends good morning
students from the class of 2026
transfer students and eli whitney
students and visiting international
students welcome to yale
and family members and friends in my
role as dean of yale college i extend my
warm welcome to you as well along with
gratitude for everything you've done in
supporting and guiding these young
adults
the opening assembly is one of my
favorite formal events of the academic
year because it introduces us to each
other just as you our new students have
begun introducing
yourselves to your classmates and i also
think of it less formally as the
beginning of a conversation with your
peers and instructors that will go on
for many years to come
you will find great fellowship here and
also you will find the great pleasure of
learning
at the beginning of his analytics the
chinese philosopher confucius provides
words that are as relevant today as they
were 2500 years ago
here he is as though addressing you now
is it not a pleasure to learn
and
when it is timely
to practice what you have learned
is it not a joy to have friends come
from afar
and i'm delighted to welcome you our new
students who come from near
or far to experience the pleasure of
learning together
yale professor ang ping chin
emphasizes that the purpose of learning
for confucius
consisted in the opportunity to develop
our moral and aesthetic sensibilities
to fulfill our humanity
and to do so with humility
in a parallel with socrates who lived
about a century later we know most of
what confucius taught through
conversations that he had and accounts
of his disciples in fact his book the
analect is known in chinese as lunyu
which means conversations or dialogues
and like these ancient thinkers the
community that you are now joining is
one that learns through dialogue
thoughtful conversation can allow each
of us to develop our own sensibilities
and to fulfill our humanity
the elk college community has a long
history shaped by the many generations
of students who
have come before you and this week more
than fifteen hundred of you have come to
new haven from all over the world
no single racial or ethnic group makes
up a majority in this very diverse
student body almost a fifth of you will
be in the first generation in your
families to graduate from a four-year
college approximately a fifth of you
have received pell grants for
lower-income students 128 applied
through the quest bridge program 47 were
admitted through the transfer and eli
whitney students program
13 of you are u.s military veterans and
21 of you began your college education
at a community college
here here
and together you represent 51 states and
territories of the united states and
more than 50 countries amidst this great
diversity you also share much in common
you are promising students with wide
horizons and an excitement about
learning now when you hear me talk about
horizons i should say that when i wrote
the speech i was expecting good weather
so i'm hoping that the you know the
horizon will hold for at least a little
bit longer
together you've come to yale to pursue a
broad liberal education and you will
find one here in both formal and
informal settings here we stand in front
of sterling memorial library the heart
of campus which holds over two million
books in all fields of knowledge and i
will say to you all undergraduates that
while underneath you
is the cross campus library which is a
great place to study do go up into the
stacks of sterling even if you're not
going to take out any books just to get
a sense of the range of knowledge that
is out there
and that you might someday explore
recognizing that in your whole lifetime
you won't make it through all two
million books
but you'll learn in the classrooms and
the discussion sections that start next
week you'll learn in the libraries and
the galleries and the laboratories where
you will broaden and test what you've
learned
and in the desk or the carol that you
may reserve for solitary study
and you'll experience the less formal
part of your education when you talk
with people around you in the student
groups that you join
with your instructors during their
office hours or with the stranger or new
friends sitting beside you at the long
table in your residential college dining
hall
yale's traditions and communities form
their own civil society that exists in
parallel with the formal curriculum
taught by the professors
of course you're here to pursue the
formal study but i also encourage you to
explore various ways to learn outside
the classroom or the library this is a
campus designed often intentionally and
sometimes just by happy accident for
conversation
together the books and the classrooms
and the more informal lessons that
you'll learn from each other all of
these form part of a single broader
conversation the conversation of a
scholarly community that defines the
pursuit of knowledge in a great
university
now you come here knowing the state of
public discourse in our polarized
society you know already that at times
it simply reaffirms our existing beliefs
at other times it devolves into
partisanship or even violence
universities are not immune to dogma but
they do aspire to a higher type of
conversation
as you join or start your own
conversations in the semesters ahead
think about how you can expand your
horizons
one of the distinctive things about
human experience is that each of us is
born in a particular body at a
particular time and place
and therefore we see the world from a
given perspective
but we also have the chance to expand
our worldview as we grow and learn and
travel
the poet tennyson has a beautiful image
of this kind of learning in his poem
ulysses
he writes
i am a part of all that i have met
yet all experience is an arch where
through gleams that untraveled world
whose margin fades forever and forever
when i move there's always something to
learn just over the horizon
whether you've traveled a long way to
get here or whether you've lived all
your life in new haven you may feel that
sense of an expanding horizon as you
meet new friends and explore new
intellectual territory
i've spent almost half my life at yale
so i see the world from a very
particular vantage point but i've also
spent a lot of time thinking about how
education allows us to transcend the
limits of our horizons in his book truth
and method
an important book about historical
interpretation
the german philosopher hans georg
gadamer wrote that the horizon
is the range of vision that includes
everything that can be seen from a
particular vantage point
and he argued that understanding
involves what he called a fusion of
horizons in which we begin become more
thoughtful about how our own assumptions
and the way we see things
correspond to and relate to someone
else's vantage point
for a godammer interpreting an ancient
text or having a conversation or
dialogue with another person
involves opening ourselves up to
reassessing our own assumptions
now he focuses on interpersonal and
humanistic knowledge but a similar
process is at work in testing scientific
hypotheses in fact
the work of understanding and even just
the work of living in this world
involves a constant mental journey
through time and space that develops our
views and changes our horizons a journey
like the one that ulysses made what the
greeks call an odyssey
it involves an ongoing metaphorical
conversation where we question our own
assumptions and prejudices through our
encounters with other people
ideally if we're open to growing we can
talk to people whose standpoints differ
from our own and we can learn from those
conversations
a crucial in fact even a defining
prerequisite of learning especially at
the university level is the willingness
to open ourselves
to views and ideas and even ways of life
that challenge our assumptions
either so that we can learn to defend
uh our assumptions and understand them
or in some cases to change and to
reassess those assumptions
this doesn't mean that you need to
accept every idea that your professors
or fellow students propose to you but in
the years ahead
your job will be to consider the new
ideas you encounter with an open mind to
weigh new perspectives and arguments and
to arrive at your own views about
matters of great importance for
yourselves and for your futures
matters such as the nature of justice
the understanding of the natural world
the meaning of art the purposes of life
you will explore these questions not
only in your classes but also over meals
in your dining halls on the athletic
fields in your campus jobs and your
student organizations as volunteers
serving the community or in any of the
many pursuits open to you as a student
one of the greatest opportunities to
learn at yale comes from the peer effect
that's the chance to interact with
talented people your own age the
nigerian novelist chimamanda adichie who
also happens to have received her
master's degree at yale offers a similar
version to godhammer's a similar vision
to godomers when she discusses learning
about other people's experiences
especially in the context of living in a
college community so godhammer focuses
on understanding different horizons
through time and history uh dj
emphasizes listening to different
stories through space and geography in
her speech on the danger of a single
story she tells of arriving at the age
of 19 at another fine american
university i won't mention the name of
the other university
where her roommate knew nothing about
nigeria and made certain stereotypical
assumptions about adichie's homeland and
way of life
so at first adiche was annoyed at her
roommate's lack of understanding but
after spending some time in the united
states and thinking about her own
limited knowledge of rural parts of
nigeria that she had never visited
adichie came to realize that her
roommate's assumptions were due to her
limited exposure to more accurate
stories about africa
adichie goes on to tell both positive
and negative stories of her child and
and then she says
all of these stories make me who i am
but to insist only on these negative
stories is to flatten my experience and
to overlook the many other stories that
formed me
the single story creates stereotypes and
the problem with stereotypes is not that
they are untrue but that they are
incomplete
they make one story become the only
story
adichie concludes that it is impossible
to engage properly with a place or a
person without engaging with all of the
stories of that place and that person
it is all too easy to make assumptions
about others that we meet or to take
offense at assumptions that others make
about us but our goal is to engage in
dialogue so that we can overcome initial
misunderstandings and learn from one
another
as you settle into your residential
colleges and begin your classes i invite
you to participate in a dialogue
like confucius enjoy the pleasure of
learning like ulysses seek out new
worlds
like god immerse strive to expand your
horizon of expectations
like adichie enjoy it
like a dj explore the complexity of
other people's stories share your own
stories and create new stories together
you may find the most interesting
conversations in seminars or lab
meetings or you may find them in your
extracurricular activities or late at
night in the college buttery
you will find those conversations where
you seek them
in order for them to succeed i ask you
to open yourselves to learning from each
other
enter into conversation in a spirit of
generosity
assume good intentions
value complexity and nuance over
self-assurance and
stereotype these conversations are an
integral part of your el education
the lessons they teach you will show you
how to develop as human beings and they
will show you how to shape the
conversations that shape our society
thank you and welcome to yale
hmm
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
is
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
good morning everyone
thank you dean lewis for those inspiring
remarks
it is
truly
a thrill
to welcome all of you our entering
students and your family members
to our campus
for our yale college opening assembly
today is the official start
of your undergraduate education at yale
and on behalf of all my colleagues here
on the stage with me we're delighted
this day has arrived
as you know yael's motto is light and
truth
looks at whereitas in latin urim
vittumim in hebrew
and you will see it etched ubiquitously
on crests around campus
today i want to speak with you about the
part of our motto we share
with many other universities around the
world through their mission
ethos culture
and that is
or truth
for several years now
even as the world struggled to contain a
public health crisis
we have witnessed
the virulent spread of deceptive
information
even outright lies
we've seen an assault on expertise an
assault on scientific
and other scholarly findings
indeed
an assault on truth
hardly a day passes without a report on
someone who has discovered in the
comfort of his or her own home that the
scientific experts are wrong about covet
hardly a day goes by when someone on the
internet does not spin some new
fact-free conspiracy theory
historical events we know to be true
are denied by individuals with nefarious
motives
here are five brief examples
early earlier this year
some in our country including those in
positions of leadership
depicted a violent mob's attempt to
disrupt the most basic functioning of
our democracy by denying an election
outcome
as legitimate political discourse
as destructive wildfires severe drought
in some places historic flooding in
others portend a catastrophic climate
emergency
we see those
fateful to unfounded skepticism
disregard overwhelming scientific
consensus
in some counties in the united states
half of the residents still do not
believe global climate change is real
in recent months vladimir putin has
propagated misinformation about rooting
out nazis as the motivation for his
unprovoked
invasion of ukraine
social media platforms have been
mobilized to incite or stoke ethnic
violence by propagating falsehoods in
countries like myanmar and ethiopia
and finally a recent defamation trial
focused on a notorious conspiracy
theorist
who claims that the murder of 20 school
children and six adults in sandy hook
connecticut
about a half hour's drive from here
was staged by the u.s government
of course spreading misinformation
is not new
history teems with the haunting
consequences
of lies
philosopher hannah arendt on whom yale
bestowed an honorary degree in 1971
writes of some of humanity's darkest
chapters
and the malignant regimes that authored
them
the ideal subject of totalitarian rule
she says is not
the convinced nazi or the convinced
communist
it is
rather
people for whom the distinction between
fact and fiction that is the reality of
experience
and the distinction between true and
false that is the standards of thought
no longer
exist
yes malevolence can feast on the
environment devoid of where it is
and at stake therefore
in the abiding search for truth
is humanity itself
for our part
colleges and universities must combat
the spread of misinformation propaganda
and conjured conspiracy theories first
by supporting faculty
they generate scientific data and
scholarly insight
faculty must be free to disseminate
knowledge and teach you to think
critically about ideas and their sources
but to do so effectively our
institutions of higher education faculty
and students
must be open to engaging with diverse
ideas whether conventional or
unconventional
of the left
or of the right
it is yell's obligation to address the
credibility crisis
for we have long stood for the pursuit
of truth
and devoted ourselves to it
colleges and universities like yale are
home to artists and scholars and
scientists and practitioners who spend
their entire lives searching for truth
yet the growing polarization in society
around ideas spoken of by your deen
whether embraced or is chewed by a
particular faction impedes the search
for truth and threatens to erode public
confidence in expertise
minimizing the impact of universities
precisely when unvarnished truth
is so desperately needed
faculty and students indeed the
university itself
will be viewed as reliable sources of
information if we do not appear closed
off to unpopular or otherwise
non-mainstrea ideas from thoughtful
individuals responsibly articulated
most americans still have a positive
view of universities and consider a
college education important for future
success
but confidence that higher education has
a salubrious impact on society is eroded
by a belief that we will not engage
with ideas that challenge us
so let me discuss a familiar example
that there has been a steady decline in
the percentage of college students who
believe
the freedom to express unpopular points
of view is secure
actually it is a myth that students do
not want their campuses to be home to a
broad range of perspectives
they do
recent opinion polling by the knight
foundation confirms that most students
believe it is more important to be
exposed to all types of speech
than to protect people by prohibiting
offensive or biased speech
what some refer to as cancel culture is
not the dominant ideology of students
here at yale
which is home to the country's oldest
collegiate debate society
students across the political spectrum
can engage in spirited yet civil
discussions
yale college students have selected
hillary clinton as a class day speaker
and honored both george h.w bush and
george w bush as yale undergraduate
lifetime achievement award recipients
and the university has hosted
interactions between individuals with
ideological differences such as a recent
conversation
between emily bazelon and ross stutthat
and another one among four former
secretaries of state democrats and
republicans
but let's be frank
it can be difficult to articulate
unpopular views on college campuses
that night foundation survey that i
cited a moment ago suggests that only
about half of all students feel
comfortable offering
dissenting opinions
so we need to build
on an existing desire among students to
engage every day in classrooms and
dining halls and meeting spaces
with different viewpoints
and to appreciate the importance of
expressing their disagreement
with one another
indeed in a university setting we must
be able to distinguish
emphatically legitimate dissent
from outright deceit
we must make room
for beliefs we find objectionable as
faithfully
as we reject falsehoods
we know to be lies
and we must therefore
nurture a bias toward openness
even and especially
when this ethos exposes us to points of
view that test our most strongly held
assumptions
such a climate
affords the search for truth
and the credibility necessary to trust
it of course as we search for truth we
must be mindful of the power and
influence of institutions like yale
we must recognize with humility
that what looks like a truth
might not be one
i think for instance of our own history
our resistance to co-education for so
long
or our leadership at one time
in eugenics
with power comes great responsibility
these disturbing realities
are why some
are reluctant even to use the word truth
in describing our mission
nonetheless at yale i've often observed
our faculty our faculty actively
encouraging students to interrogate data
and other ideas presented to them and
i've seen students change their minds
when confronted with contrary evidence
every one of you
will have that experience
as part of your yale education
i suspect you'll have it often
you can enroll in courses that bring
together pairs of professors
representing different disciplines who
model how looking at a problem from
divergent perspectives can lead to new
insights
a course on film taught by a film
historian
and a physicist
a course on the nature of choice taught
by a philosopher and an economist
a course on transgender health taught by
faculty members from american studies
and the school of nursing
similarly in a recent semester three
experts from across the political
spectrum
co-taught of course on the crisis of
liberalism covering the obama and trump
presidencies
we will continue to create opportunities
like these for you to have open
conversations about contentious complex
issues
opportunities rooted in the reality that
no ideological block can claim ownership
of truth
that facts pledge no fealty to any of
our preferred conclusions
and therefore that evidence must guide
the beliefs we hold
rather than conform to them
in considering this imperative i'm
reminded of the book the death of truth
by michiko
kakutani a winner of the pulitzer prize
an alumna of yale college class of 1976
and a champion of the sense of truth we
seek to promote
kakutani's stirring appeal for reason
and objectivity concludes with an
especially if not unnervingly relevant
warning for our era issued by james
madison
a popular government without popular
information or the means of acquiring it
is but a prologue to a force i'm sorry
is but a prologue to a farce
or a tragedy
or perhaps both
indeed without commonly agree agreed
upon facts kakutani posits not
republican facts and not democratic
facts
not the alternative facts of today's
silo world
there can be no rational debate over
policies
no substantive means of evaluating
candidates or political office and no
way to hold elected officials
accountable
to the people
without truth
democracy is hobbled
the founders recognize this
and those seeking democracy's survival
must recognize it
today that was all a quote from kakutan
i think too of james hatch an
extraordinary yell undergraduate who
spent over two decades with the naval
special warfare command
before returning to complete his college
education
as he wrote the climate at yale is one
where most students understand that
there has to be a place where people can
assault ideas openly and discuss them
vigorously
and respectfully
in order to improve
the state of humanity
is committed to the responsibility of
promoting the public's trust in academic
research
expertise
and the value of higher education
by ensuring that mr hatch's experience
is typical
of every student
every day
in every classroom
philosophy 181 reflects this
responsibility
in her course philosophy and the science
of human nature
yale's faculty of arts and sciences dean
tamar gendler
ties contemporary cognitive science
which has helped us to gain an
understanding of how our minds operate
to the work of ancient philosophers
students in her class consider a new
plato's allegory of the cave
in which people mistake shadows on the
wall
for reality
dean gendler walks her students through
this allegory to challenge them to
consider this question
how do you discover truth
given that the human mind
is imperfect
of course our limitations pose no
impediment to the search for truth for
they are in fact what can power the
curiosity necessary to sustain it
by embracing our humility
we can broaden
our understanding
so at yale
we will not merely reaffirm what you
already think
as you arrive
we will instead provoke you to uncover
all you do not know
before you leave
we will fine-tune your ability to sift
facts
from falsehood
for the core of a liberal education
is comprised of reason
logic
and critical thinking
soon you will be the beneficiary of such
an education
yet it behooves you
also
to be an active participant in it
as students
and then
in due course
as alumni
and so today
as you begin your college career
i call on all of us
to promote a truth-seeking climate at
yale
in every seminar
in every residential college
and in every late night conversation
to echo our dean
by being willing to entertain ideas with
which we do not agree
by being willing to extend grace and
assume positive intent
by listening carefully
by thinking deeply
and by speaking
with empathy
and understanding
let us together elevate
the virtues of tolerance and engagement
and reject the culture of public shaming
doxxing
and ostracism
and in time-tested tradition
let us strengthen the open discourse
that has for centuries been a hallmark
of our intellectual community
at yale
and that has produced the scholarship
and scientific breakthroughs
that have improved the world
well beyond it
by doing so
you can develop expertise
and also help
to rescue its standing
you can
in an increasingly dark world
bring wary tests
to looks
and perhaps equally
as vital
in a fragmented world
bring looks
to where it does
light
to truth
welcome
to yale
[Applause]
time
passes quickly
[Music]
[Music]
fading
from
your ears
[Music]
close your eyes
[Music]
r
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
my
god
[Music]
[Applause]
as we ready ourselves
to step out onto new ground
in this daunting yet inspiring liminal
space
of the unknown next
we begin a poignant turn of goodbyes and
hellos
that invite laughter tears
challenge choice
discovery and pride
let us go forth with deep trust in
certain knowledge
that in this place each and every one of
us is welcome
that in this place
we will both stumble
and soar
that in this place
love surrounds us
beauty can surprise us
in this place
light and truth awaits us
on this day and every day forward
may all that is holy shine upon us
and tenderly bless
our every breath
may we go in shalom
in salam
in shanti
may we go in peace
let us begin